[Music]
stay where you are smith
[Music]
it was [ __ ] too good to be true [ __ ]
[ __ ] ah [ __ ]
hey everyone my name is peacemaker and
if i wasn't clear by the outfit i am a
genuine superhero and protector of peace
and i'm agent emilia harcourt i'm here
to provide a factual account of
christopher smith's history with our
agency because we know that he won't be
doing that
[Music]
this whole thing kicked off and amanda
waller came to me and asked me to lead a
super team to save the world close not
exactly the aforementioned super team
was comprised of highly dangerous
prisoners serving time at bellrev smith
included for the duration of the mission
i was in the communications hub with
john economos and amanda waller smith
was not the leader robert dubois aka
bloodsport was put in charge of team two
thank god my team was the real team team
one were a bunch of losers disloyal and
scared shitless i think there was even a
[ __ ] ferret or something he was a
weasel but yes team one was a decoy
sacrificed for the larger mission that's
not to say my team didn't have its
challenges i mean the biggest challenge
being this jackass or the stupid accent
whose biggest accomplishment was
figuring out how to hide a flamethrower
in a scuba suit yeah it was a dick
measuring contest between smith and
dubois from moment one the exact number
of friendlies they took out is still
confidential [ __ ] that guy we can check
the tape and see who took out more
gorillas soldier gorillas not funky
gorillas okay
monkeys would have been better you
killed allies
not saying you should kill monkeys i
don't want you to please don't go kill
monkeys okay don't confuse me here
anyway we reach our target lab called
guggenheim or heineken or something
yotenheim
yotenheim
and inside we uncovered this alien
starfish that was captured from space
and this starfish by the way can control
mines pretty [ __ ] dangerous weapon if
you ask me
unfortunately flag went rogue
rick flagg thought the truth was more
important than peace i can't let you do
that colonel excuse me let me be clear
nothing is more important than peace
am i happy about what i did no
peacemaker
what a joke
but then mr microphone shoots me in a
building [ __ ] follows me
lights out
wake up in the hospital three months
later and i'm being asked to save the
world
again obviously we didn't have a lot of
options pretty sure we would have chosen
anyone else if we had the chance
but the world really is in imminent
danger so let's just hope that smith can
step up to the plate i can step up to
any plate you got i [ __ ] love
baseball american is apple pie so the
new mission is codenamed project
butterfly i'll tell you right now if
there's an author about to be unleashed
in the world i will rip off its giant
ass wings and fry its body with a
massive [ __ ] magnifying glass that is
not what project butterfly is okay i
mean they can't all be kaijus
are we good here
we have a lot of work to do
always [ __ ] around man
you